hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Crash Bandicoot now
if you're seeing this and you're
wondering hey part two what the hell
happened to part one then you didn't see
my livestream or you didn't see the
archive of it I'll put a link in the
description below I was playing this
game for about two hours and in those
two hours I practically lost my mind and
I don't even know how this game isn't
that difficult but I say that now and
I'm gonna dive back into it exactly
where I left off but that does not mean
that I'm not gonna lose my mind again so
let's get back into it shall we
the wumpa Islands got to get back into
the Whomper fruit but I feel relaxed I
feel a lot better now I I feel like a
lot of this game is compounding stress
and you get flustered as time goes on
and you just start to lose your skill so
I'm just gonna dive right back into it
I've never finished this game I never
even played this game as a kid as I
mentioned in the livestream but now that
I'm playing it again I can see what the
appeal would have been it's kind of like
a lion king for the Super Nintendo just
really precise jumping all the time okay
left nothing alright I'm not stupid
there that looked like there was
something to the Lord here we go OOP you
okay I didn't realize you were enemies
because I've never seen you before so
yeah was that a game over I just got
back alright fine it's fine it's fine
let's call mulligan on that one let's
just say that was for practice and
getting back into the swing of things
and now it's gonna commit
okay tick - I'm really not that bad
anyone that was watching in the last
room knows that I've actually wasn't
doing that terribly in this I wasn't
getting all the prizes mind you huh but
I whoa hey all right
but I wasn't doing the worst in the
world I bet if you spin against me
you're gonna die I hate that I hate that
I hate that huh
okay good so what's oh the cold ones are
fine they don't cold me today okay
my wampum man is gone but I've still got
dreams oh boy
okay okay I don't know what that does I
don't know why that is or why that does
but why does it give me so many question
blocks uh-huh ish okay this seems
relatively easy coming back into the
swing of things considering what I just
came from which is a whole lot of Hell
so maybe it's just serving as an intro
but if I jump on you don't you die oh
crap
right as soon as I say jump in GG hmm
did those die if you jump on them these
will die this will die I should have
gotten that blocks a lot of this game
just comes down to patience which I
don't have any love I made a bad move
[Music]
what's wrong with me oh yeah okay we're
fine do doodlee do okay doing all right
so far so goo back to this part which
should have been the easy part just get
apples and then go wrong we'll be trying
to overcomplicate it with my [ __ ]
okay good get over there okay okay just
as a safety precaution I'm not gonna
assume that anything can be jumped on
and I'm always going to spin no matter
what I do
oh not for you though yeah alright what
is that okay ah you almost made me miss
the goddamn checkpoint you son of a
[ __ ] but I ain't gonna be forwarded
that badly
no okay oh no today okay my wampa went
away oh I don't like that
yiii okay got two of those which means
the bonus is gonna be having in shrewd
enough oh my god
huh okay like I didn't want to go house
I jumped on that before the womp oh god
oh that's right dude I don't even know
if the wampa guy is the right name for
that guy but I don't even care at this
point I'm gonna name people whatever
guttural song
I forgot that guy can sigh I don't have
my womp game over our neck oh I'm in a
hurry why am I in a hurry hurry always
gets me go ahead okay so I think I gotta
go under you ha ha ha oh he hi hi ho d
ho JJ Hardy I got this ok so just don't
get blasted in the asses by the steamy
we me
oh boy speed run poof girl why do I
always shout speed run right before I do
horribly Oh No Afghan ambitions no
reason to continue going anywhere oh my
god I thought I was going to die look at
this learning experience from patience
huh man you think that I wouldn't I see
you you can't hide from me I know you're
trying to hide give me over there ok huh
hey yeah do you made the bonus baby
please give me the bonus you may be my
sister I'm not a hundred percent sure on
the dynamics here hey two three four
oink oink oink one one two three four
doink
one two three four nine one one one
you three let me get this one just
engaged war doink
wink wink point one two three four oh
one k-- oink oink oink oink oink oink
oink one two three four five do I not
get any lives for that but those are
what I need oh boy
alright fine then gonna be that way is
that that better be it this is
teleporter
oh I forgot about that I forgot about
the lateral motion in this okay wait
patiently for the steam and then go yes
I gotta checkpoint oh that was farther
forward than I thought it was I think it
was very forgiving me on me on that one
yum yum
hey can you come back here you do the
little [ __ ] yeah I got patience right I
can wait all day baby all I guess I
could have gotten that with a shoe I
didn't know that I didn't even try
yeah unless they tried I keep flipping
but you would I don't like the look at
this I didn't like that looks like it
might have bounced me up into goop and I
don't like goop as much as the internet
might say otherwise i'll i don't i don't
like goop yeah you're okay okay okay
okay all right got it got it good you
okay give me some of you toss me oh I
see what you're doing oh I see what
you're doing okay
oh not yeah okay here we go
poink all right I don't know where I was
supposed to get another one of you
bastards I don't even know if there's
any secret areas ever I don't even know
secret areas exists in the world all I
know is that this game is the son of a
[ __ ] and I don't like it
yeah okay so that's same good oh ah heyo
I need all the apples I can get please
uh yeah all right oh that's a life I
want it I need a lot I need a life man
I'm really losing everything on this
playthrough here my pride my joy my life
everything pretty much Oh triple lives
why are you why are you loading me up
for something it seems like there might
be failure in my future
oh no just a reward they never get just
rewarded for anything oh boy here we go
wasn't so bad the box that broke the
Foxbat bad Nica Bandicoot name is
bandicoot another box
what's a Bandicoot anyway I have no idea
but we made it through that one okay
we did all right let's get through
another one without too much trouble cuz
I don't know how long this game actually
is in total but I mean it's part of the
trilogy I don't think I'm gonna play oh
all the games I'm barely able to get
through the the first one with my sanity
intact in fact I may still lose it by
the end of this but I just want to know
I just want to know I want to know how
much farther I have to go cuz if I'm not
even halfway through this and it only
gets harder from here
hey cortex power ok this cortex a guy
that I'm gone oh it's one of the runny
ones
alright I'm ready when am I gonna be
riding this time the hog that oh no I'm
not gonna be running at all I thought I
was gonna be you okay oh boy I don't
like that ah I don't like that what's
that about to kill me oh oh I should
have jumped on that shouldn't I yeah
okay that was close this seems like a
mistake oh this seems like a mistake I
shoulda gone the other way I was led I
was tempted okay
all right that's a weird diagonal yeah
you know it seems like it's just
workplace hazards if all these
electrical bolts are just dancing around
I mean this thing doesn't maintain
itself so I gotta imagine there's
something going on here okay that works
too
that's an option that I did and had oh
thank you for that almost spun that into
oblivion Oh take it what is this secret
okay never mind I don't want to be there
oh I should probably go that way I don't
know where this leads but okay I don't
understand this must be just one of the
other ways to go around Oh
okay let's just keep going go check
point me thank you yeah at least this
ain't as bad as the prey I know I spoke
too soon that's funny that's funny
can you tell by how I'm laughing that
how that that that is funny okay
spooky Oh what is the point of this
[ __ ] what is this what is this who
made this oh yeah yeah let's let's go
with this one all right sure Hey boink
okay barely made through that all right
what do we got here oh but why am i okay
sure you know what sure hey you know I
gotta feel like I'm the [ __ ] here
because blue oh that easy huh I bet
there was some secrets in this level
because it doesn't seem like something
that would just give it up that easily
you know what I mean
I don't even know what I mean there
whatever it's fine all right up okay no
it is key well I went through relatively
easily I know I didn't get all the by a
blade ball beep move be bold be bold
beep that's hardly missing him if you
pass him on the head anyway
okay I've barrel I've been stuck in this
factory for 13 years I'm in the
generator room why why am i destroying
everything that I see his
experimentation drove me wild and I just
went crazy all over his technology went
back to the day oh hi how's it going
there buddy you look good nice gift all
right this looks like hell oh ok good
for me I don't know why I got it great
what was the point of that okay here we
go
aah
argh why are you doing this to me
righty-ho then one I hate you all right
you you I don't know what you do okay
thank you thanks for coming back for me
Oh all right got one you know why do I
want to go this way all right cool yes I
didn't want to go this way plenty of
bonuses I smack a lump of root out of
the way who needs it okay Oh God the
lateral motion oh I made it all the way
back here now
is me being stupid here we go I guess I
got an achievement I see London I see
France crash bandicoot is dead that's
the end of that achievement oh yeah yeah
sometimes I gotta go to the directional
pads just to be able to do this
eat Giambi Schwalm buh buh combo move I
just get so scared
but is it I get so scared oh oh okay
goopy goopy please
I don't know that built that over there
okay okay
I don't need to go back there again
because I highly doubt there's going to
be what I need but I'm your uncle anyway
so I can get some wampa fruit I guess
nice nice nice nice nice just as what I
wanted Oh Oh God huh there's a
checkpoint almost as if they know Oh
nothing no yeah yeah yeah
now I was learning its food me it's lit
screwed me okay oh yes okay not gonna
screw me this time are ya got ya [ __ ]
oh my god I can't see what I'm doing oh
okay here we go
[ __ ] this come on at least you get to
retry that one as many times as you want
awfully convenient of them hello good
boy
all right made some lives up I've got a
plenty of lives I've got a plenty I've
got uh plenty although the lives
uh-huh yeah do tell wait am I supposed
to go down
it looks like I'm supposed to go down
I'm gonna go down I'm supposed to go
down okay well there goes okay my
immunity just got used up and blasting
those guys into hell don't know where
I'm going
this game is going to give me an
aneurysm pun aneurysm oh now oh now I
can go down oh I don't know what
happened there but I got really confused
and scared yeah yeah like y'all like
y'all oh I must be getting close to the
end though okay okay her her it wasn't
original I did I draw I'm starting to
lose it I think okay I'm very clearly
only using the directional great why
would I want to blow those why would I
want to take the run taking the risk
here I go I don't everything's fine
boom okay I don't know why I did that
but I did it okay can I have another
checkpoint please that would be lovely
if you could do that just deliver it
right to my face please oh no no no I
asked for a checkpoint not this like
this oh my god okay we're fine almost
lost that there in my panic why are you
doing this
okay cool
pinstripe le po total T Porter odd I
don't know
oh hi okay well anyway that's okay I
think it was the boxes on the way back
from the the little snippy snippy thing
but anyway huh I think that's a good
enough point to break this episode of
crash bandicoot so I'm gonna be playing
through the full of this and I'm gonna
do it all today so in the next episode
you'll see me progressively losing my
mind more and more because I'm not gonna
take a break until I beat this this life
of mine so yeah so thank you everybody
so much for watching I hope you enjoy
this I know I did
Russian mark let me know how I did in
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]